I'm going to start by saying been a fan  of your work for a very long time it's  great to talk to you thank you  I have to listen I'm here to talk about  morning show yeah I loved leftovers  thank you loved and so I have to ask you  have you ever said what you think  happened in the finale of the leftovers  like your personal tape or is it that  you kept that close to your vest I don't  think I've ever said it out loud so I'll  ask you do you think she went through  this is what I think I think that people  have belief systems and I think that she  believes she went through because I  think we all need stories to tell  ourselves to get through this life you  know we tell ourselves stories so that  we can survive and so do I think she  went through no okay I want to commend  you for your work on that show and Damon  Lindelof it's so phenomenal thank you it  was one of the greatest experiences of  my life and it was life-changing